the nun too sees a demon valak go beyond
the walls of the Abbey into the French
Countryside to wreak havoc what will all
the Mayhem mean for The Conjuring
universe as a whole morning spoilers for
the nun too ahead
as sisters Irene and Deborah investigate
the inexplicable Devastation of valaka's
course they come to realize what the
demon is after more possessing Irene's
old friend Frenchy valak has been
searching for a powerful religious
artifact known as the eyes of Saint
Lucie the patron saint of the blind
balak has been brutally killing Lucy's
descendants so that no one can stop her
from Gaining the eyes incredible power
in the hands of a demon would be
Unthinkable Irene and Deborah track down
frenzy who has been acting as a handyman
at an all-girl score where he's gotten
close to a young teacher named Kate and
her daughter Sophie when they arrive
valak has already started to take full
control of Frenchy and even cause the
arrival of another demon an infernal
goat in all the chaos Irene ends up
finding the eyes of Saint Lucy in the
school's Chapel unfortunately Frenchy
storms in and nearly rips the eyes right
out of Irene's hands Sophie grabs the
eyes and runs towards a bell tower while
the possessed French he gives Chase
Sophie and Frenchy's cat and mouse game
causes a bell tower to fall apart Irene
and Deborah rush in to try and save
Sophie luckily no one is hurt during the
towers collapse but Frenchie is still up
and in pursuit of Sophie Irene uses the
power of the eyes to freeze Frenchy and
to weaken him it could ultimately kill
him this initially seems to be the case
as Frenchie lies on the ground but then
he reawakens to steal the eyes from
Irene's hands which gives valak the
power that she's been craving her eyes
turn yellow and she grows to a massive
size towering over everyone Irene and
Deborah then notice that the floor is
covered in wine which reminds Irene
about the power of faith on a train ride
earlier in the film Deborah tells Irene
that she has doubts questioning what
really makes communion wine the blood of
Christ Irene says that his faith that
makes people believe and they use that
sense of Faith to consecrate the wine
ultimately defeating valak by dousing
her in it
you can find your faith when the time
comes once valak has defeated and her
dog presence over the score Has Lifted
Irene is left to changed woman during
the final fight with valak Irene
remembers a time with her mother and
connects it to what she's learned about
the descendants of Saint Lucy she
determines that she's likely one of
Lucy's descendants it's something that
osmally gives her power to beat valak
this time and makes her realize that she
is destined to defeat valaka once and
for all this Revelation makes Cyrene
anything but gleeful though she still
knows that friend she is susceptible to
valak's power and doesn't think that
he's totally shaken valak's control over
him even with the lifting of the dark
Aura around the school Irene can feel
that there is still a haunting presence
around Frenchie himself yes he walks
away with Kate and Sophie to likely
start a better life but Irene knows that
it won't be long until valaka gains
control over him again
like the first nun movie The nunsu makes
a direct connection to Conjuring
franchise protagonist Ed and Lorraine
Warren decades later fans are treated to
a mid-credits scene that starts with the
sound of a ringing phone both Ed and the
rain come to answer the call and it
seems like the person on the other end
is asking for their help it's unlike the
Warrens are simply refuse a request for
their assistance so they obviously seem
like they're ready to head somewhere new
but where are they going is this
mid-credit scene simply a tease for the
upcoming fourth Conjuring film or is it
connected to the events of the nun too
meaning that the Warrens could be facing
off against falaka once again the answer
isn't clear for now but the
possibilities are very exciting for the
future of the franchise
more than none two could simply be seen
as a filler story for valak that sets
the stage for a bigger conflict in a
future film it does shed some
interesting new light in the Demonic
nun's intentions although valak hasn't
really seemed like a fault with any
motivations aside from tormenting the
people around her this film shows a type
of plan she can concut she takes over
Frenchie to not only become a dark
plague across France but to find Saint
Lucy's eyes and she doesn't want to
destroy these holy relics but use of
power for herself valak clearly has
bigger plans and the way she's depicted
in the nun too perhaps hints at a
developing storyline for the antagonist
that could play out in a future movie it
doesn't seem like valak is completely
defeated by the end of the film and
there's potential for her to be a major
part of the next Conjuring movie The Nun
2 isn't just a simple return for valak
it gives her intriguing motivations and
planning capabilities that could impact
plenty of elements of The Conjuring
series to come one of the overarching
themes that fuels the debate between
Irene and Deborah is whether faith is
strong enough to make miracles happen
Deborah tells Irene that she desperately
wants to see real-life Miracles which
the church believes Irene performed when
she first defeated valak
you performed a miracle
church needs another after her mother
died Deborah started to lose her faith
question biblical stories and doubt that
the Miracles that Jesus performed were
true as mentioned earlier Deborah
particularly doubts transubstantiation
the belief that wine actually becomes
Christ's blood drawing communion but
then in the end valak is actually
defeated by a combination of communion
wine and the sister's Faith given that
it works the film highlights have a
strong sense of Faith Can Empower people
to go beyond themselves and do things
they often would think are impossible
maybe even Miracles their strong belief
allows them to tap into a power they
generally wouldn't see and this what
enables Irene and Deborah to defeat a
Monumental evil the Revelation that
Irene has a personal connection to Saint
Lucie might seem a little force and
unclear when it happens as valak's power
grows and she wreaks Havoc Irene
remembers a conversation with her mother
about having her eyes and she starts to
put some things together although the
film never confirms it concretely it's
alluded that Irene is another descendant
of Saint Lucy while it feels a little
too good to be true there are small
Clues throughout the film that do point
to this conclusion for instance during
Irene's vision of Lucy losing her eyes
Lucy actually looks a bit like Irene
perhaps a small hint about their
familial connection there are also some
thematic connections between Lucy and
Irene a key part of Lucy's story in
Christianity is that she would often
deliver food to those in need in the
dark wearing a crown of candles or
carrying a lantern while she made
deliveries in the middle of the night
that's idea of being a beacon of light
in the darkness is undoubtedly true for
Irene as well in that she's tasked with
keeping the light of the church alive in
places that have been darkened and
corrupted by valak's presence so Irene's
connections to Saint Lucy do make a
little more sense and given those Therma
similarities no announcement has been
made about another nun movie going into
development but the ending makes it
pretty clear where the story is heading
based on the mid-credits scene it seems
that the Warrens are about to get
involved in another Clash for the valak
which makes sense the first film
featured a scene that saw the Warrens
performing an exorcism on Frenchie which
led to the Rain being connected with
valak as seen in The Conjuring too so it
does make sense that the Warrens would
finally become involved but will we see
that in the next Mainline Conjuring
entry or somewhere else the Warrens
don't solely appear in films with
Conjuring in the title the third
Annabelle film Annabelle comes home was
largely focused on the Warren Family
after all there's nothing that says the
Warrens can't be involved in a potential
third nun film there's no doubt that
valak is returning at some point and it
could be for another nun movie or maybe
the events of the nunsu will play into
the upcoming fourth Conjuring film yes
the nun films and The Conjuring movies
are set decades apart but maybe there's
a way to get sisters to Issa and Vera
Farmiga on screen together the fourth
Conjuring movie is titled The Conjuring
last right which could hint toward valak
being involved in some sort of grand
finale that ties the entire universe
together we still don't know much about
the plot but the inclusion of the
Warrens and the mid-credits scene of the
nun 2 opens lots of possibilities it
would be great to uh eventually bring it
back full circle bring the non-story and
tie it back into The Conjuring despite
Warner Brothers having some ambitious
plans for The Conjuring Universe it
doesn't matter what the studio has
planned if the current writer's Guild of
America and sag-aftra actors union
strikes aren't resolved as long as the
strikes are ongoing Warner Brothers
won't be able to start development on
The Conjuring last rites a potential
than them three or make any
announcements about the future of The
Conjuring Universe fans could be waiting
a while for a potential collaboration
between the farm migas sisters the box
office performance of the nun 2 could
change things as well a third man film
will likely depend on the second's box
office Performance Plus Warner Brothers
is currently in a legal battle with
Bonnie Aarons the actor who plays valak
over Fair compensation for the use of
her image on merchandise the studio is
facing obstacles on multiple fronts the
end of the wga and psych Astra strike
seems nowhere in sight as tensions
continue to rise between major Studios
including Warner Brothers and writers
and actors looking for a fair deal the
enticing potential future of The
Conjuring universe as presented in the
nun too will likely stay at a standstill
for at least a little while longer